f of x is equal to nine minus x actually
it should be nine minus x squared and g
of x is equal to five x squared plus two
x plus one and then they say find
f plus g of x and this looks a little
bit bizarre what kind of notation is
this and that's really the core of this
problem is just to realize that when
someone writes f plus g in parentheses
like this of x this is just notation for
so f plus g of x i just rewrote it this
is the same thing this is just a kind of
shorthand notation for
f of x
plus g of x you could view f plus g as a
new function that's created by adding
the other two functions but when you
view it like this so this is really what
we have to find then you just have to
add these two functions so f of x
f of x they've given the definition
right over there is 9 minus x squared
9 minus x squared
and g of x they've given
the definition right over here
is
is five x squared plus two x plus one so
when you add f of x to g of x this is
going to be equal to and i'm just
rewriting a lot of things just to make
it clear
the f of x part is 9 minus x squared and
then you have the plus
i'll do that in yellow plus the g of x
part which is 5
x squared plus 2x
plus 1. and now we can just simplify
this a little bit we can say let me just
get rid of the parentheses i'll just
rewrite it so this is equal to
this is equal to 9 minus x squared plus
since this is a positive we can just we
don't have to worry about the
parentheses so plus
5 x squared plus 2x plus 1. and then we
have two x squared terms or second
degree terms we have 5x squared and then
we have negative x squared 5x squared
minus x squared is 4x squared
so you get 4x squared when you combine
these two terms you only have one
first degree term 2x there so plus
2x and then you have two constant terms
or zero degree terms and so you have the
nine and you have the one and nine plus
one
gets us to ten so we're done f plus g
f plus g of x is equal to 4x squared
plus 2x plus 10. notice this is a new
function that's created by summing the
function definitions of f and g